maintenant il ya un point qui est assez
marrant c'est justement le point de
différenciation qu'on va avoir son
smartphone par rapport au ps marc 2019
et aujourd'hui aux besoins jeu alors
vous allez voir j'ai un petit jeu c'est
rigolo on a d'un côté le au nord disent
leur côté le huawei le paceman 2019
on va essayer de deviner lequel est le
smartphone de voyous et le quel
smartphone d honneur vous allez voir
c'est un peu compliqué attention vous
êtes très vous avez dix secondes de
smartphones lequel est celui de huawei
lequel s-vidéo nord attention ils se
ressemblent c'est pas très facile
attention de seconde 1 2 peuvent aller
vous marquez son commentaire dans ma
main gauche un smartphone dans ma main
droite l'autre vous marquez en bas main
droite main gauche 6 et le au nord 10
lancers le huawei le paceman 2009
allez-y y mettait la pause marquée ça et
après on reprend
elle
en fait c'est vachement dur à savoir
parce que ces deux smartphones se
ressemblent énormément vous avez dans
les deux cas la petite encoche goutte
d'eau vous avez dans les deux cas un
écran de 6,21 pousse donc face aux
produits c'est très compliqué de savoir
qui est qui alors celui-là avec le dos
noir c'est le webp smar 2019 tandis que
celui là c'est avec le double c'est le
au nord disent leur lot dans des salles
ait eu très contente pour vous en parler
parce que l'année dernière il avait déjà
présenté les honore 9 lite voilà cette
année son petit frère le au nord 10 la
cool alors l'honneur neuf mois c'est
justine et si vous savez pas justin
c'est ma compagne et c'est elle qui l'a
ça fait un an qu'elle utilise et
franchement elle est très contente et je
trouve le smartphone est assez cool
alors il est pas c'est pas une bombe
atomique avait tout ce qu'elle veut être
un peu plus faiblard notamment sur la
partie photo m'a manqué un peu de
contraste bon c'est un fait
extraordinaire cette nouvelle version
2010 9 vient très clairement prendre la
suite mais sans grande prise de risque
néanmoins c'est un smartphone que je
trouve vraiment bien vu le
positionnement tarifaire il est très
intéressant et je vais vous dire
pourquoi
déjà je vous parlais de son design que
je trouve franchement très très bien
réussi vous avez ce design accepte
toutes petites encoches qui est très
sympa en coach boudo vraiment fin 2018
mais qui reste très actuel petit haut
parleur qui est dissimulé la menton qui
n'est pas le plus lourd en franche mans
ça va je trouve que du point de vue de
la face avant d'aller bien je vous
parlais l'écran dans quelques instants
le dos à dos plastique à l'ordre points
négatifs
il prend les traces de doigts comme son
petit frère le paceman 2019
les rayures également il marque très
rapidement les caméras sont bien situés
et elle dépasse légèrement n'est pas
trop vous avez un effet 3d avec un petit
angle qu'il est surcoté
je trouve ça bien alors sur le côté
c'est pas révolutionnaire c'est très
simple bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre bouton de volume un haut
parleur ici micro usb prise jack
ici il n'y a absolument rien et au
dessus vous avez votre lecteur de carte
sim soit denanot sim soit une anonyme
une carte micro sd on en reparle dans
quelques instants la prise en main est
bonne on trouve très facilement la
position de lecteur d'empreintes
digitales qui marche extrêmement bien
vous touche et ça marche pour
déverrouiller directement en finale face
à la recrudescence faciale ça marche
c'est très rapide
franchement de ce point de vue là en
terme de design je trouve beau je trouve
bien réussi ça c'est cool maintenant
point qu intéressant il a un écran de
qualité vous avez un écran qui occupent
90 % de la face avant
c'est un écran lcd il a une diagonale de
6,21 pouces résolution 2340 par 1080
pixels ratio 19 points 5/9 ça fait
beaucoup de si mais ce qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre la dent est ce qui
est très intéressant avec cet écran là
c'est qu'il sera parfaitement adapté
pour du multimédia et pour jouer à des
jeux vidéo typiquement cette arme est
parti d'un sac ni trop là dessus c'est
cool c'est pas le smartphone le plus
dingue le plus puissant mais par contre
pour ce un plaisir pour jouer à des jeux
voyait c'est cool vous n'allez pas jouer
à des jeux euros trop gourmand éviter
les fortes night point que mais pour
jouer à des petits jeux comme ça et même
du fait le vg résolution moyenne ça
tombera donc ça c'est cool mêmes
produits multimédia c'est franchement
sympa vous nécro paix vous meizu mais un
petit peu dans l'écran ça marche c'est
sympa donc de ce point de vue le cran et
franchement agréable
maintenant ce qu'on pouvait lui
reprocher c'est qu'il n'est pas hyper
hyper hyper lumineux donc si vous le
mettez en plein soleil vraiment face au
soleil vous allez commencer a galéré
mais il faut vraiment chercher des
histoires et le met face au soleil vous
allez à l'extérieur au soleil
j'ai fait le test ça marche
rassurez-vous franchement c'est cool
maintenant je sais pas si vous le voyez
mais le tir quand même un petit peu vers
le bleu pour corriger ces traits fassiez
vous allez dans affichage vous allez
dans mode des températures de couleur et
là vous pouvez venir modifier légèrement
vous le réchauffé faites ce que vous
voulez vous allez voir ça corrige c'est
vachement sympa maintenant y'a un truc
qui pas aux fenêtres sus un peu comme
sur le ps marc le problème c'est l'audio
l'audio beaucoup trop médium et e'lara
château sans fil vachement mal aux
oreilles jeune patron et et lorsque vous
le coûté au casque
exactement comme sur le pré ce marc 2019
le problème c'est que la sortie casque
est un peu faiblarde
il mériterait d'avoir un poil plus de
puissance par contre il ya vraiment de
bonnes performances comme sur le web de
paix smart 2019 vous avez un kirin 710
couple est à 3 giga de ram alors si ça
vous parle pas dites vous bien que c'est
un soft qui va être suffisamment
performant pour je dirais trois quarts d
utilisation standard si vous avez besoin
de plus de puissance pour aller
notamment chercher sur des jeux sur du
multitâche il y à un moment vous
arriverez vous avez milité mais d'un
autre côté ça smartphones qui coûte un
peu plus de 200 euros on ne va pas
acheter un smartphone de ce prix là pour
venir chercher le mc de puissance le max
de performance avec ça par contre pour
un usage standard voire un peu plus ce
serait franchement tranquille et ça
marche très bien d'autant plus long
terme de stockage vous avez 64 j
un de stockage extensible comme je
lisais grâce à une carte microsd jusqu'à
512 giga donc ça aussi c'est super cool
en plus de ça l'autonomie est solide
vous pouvez obtenir jusqu'à deux jours
deux jours vous êtes cool vous n'êtes
pas un sauvage au départ du temps en
train de jouer à des jeux sur des applis
à droite à gauche ci et ça sur les
réseaux sociaux mais vous pouvez tenir
deux jours sans problème il a une
batterie 3400 millions perreur le tout
complètement optimisé de point de vue
logiciel derrière ça marche ça
fonctionne pour moi vous le tenez entre
une journée une journée et demie si vous
utilisez souvent votre smartphone
si vous êtes vraiment un sauvage vous
allez garder une journée par l'autre
attention il n'a pas de recharge rapide
on a dessus une recharge en micro usb il
faut un peu plus de deux heures pour
leur mettre une recharge complète donc
très voyez organisez vous c'est un truc
qu'il faut un petit peu anticipée pour
pas se retrouver en galère notamment
dans les transports en commun si elle ça
si vous êtes dans le gps et compagnie ça
peut rapidement être compliqué donc
l'autonomie est pas mal mais prévoyez le
coût de la recharge pas ce que je vous
dis c'est pas le truc qui vaille plus
vite par contre l'expérience utilisateur
au niveau de l'eau s écoule em 8,9 sur
un android 9 paille ça marche c'est
prouvé que c'est plutôt agréable après
défend pas regretter que cet os vous
installe quelques applis en plus par
défaut comme booking et compagnie bon
ceci étant dit c'est un point de détail
dans pire des cas il existe des skins si
ces applis vous ne voulez pas vous avez
qu à les mettre de côté
voilà ça c'est pas grave maintenant il
ya un point qui est assez marrant c'est
justement le point de différenciation
qu'on va avoir son smartphone par
rapport au ps mars 2019
et c'est sur la partie photo vidéo non
pas son capteur à rien parce qu'on
retrouve un 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.8 plus en 2 mégapixels qui va être là
pour les faits bouquet mais la vraie
différence fait à lavaur pouvoir vous
avez la lamelle petite encoche là dessus
vous avez une caméra de 24 mégapixels a
qu'une ouverture de f 2.0 à la
fonctionnait forcément un peu mieux que
celle du ps martin avec sa caméra de 8
mégapixels j'aimais pas particulièrement
le rendu ne tournait pas terrible le
rendu des couleurs
pas extraordinaire les contrastes pas
géniaux là dessus ça marche mieux d'une
manière générale on va se retrouver sur
des photos qui sont sensiblement les
mêmes que celles du ps martin 2010
9 il ya d'un côté la partie hardware
partie matérielle comment les forcément
sur ben appareil photo les photos n'ont
pas vraiment différente néanmoins il y à
un traitement logiciel qui semble être
un tout petit peu différent c'est pas
extraordinaire vous n'allez pas voir les
photos avec le plus gros contraste vous
n'allez pas avoir découvert sursaturé
sait pas forcément ce qu'on recherche
d'ailleurs mais vous n'allez pas à voir
des photos complètement dingue mais par
contre pour avoir quelques souvenirs
pour partager son des réseaux sociaux ça
marche c'est efficace c'est pas dingue
mais une fois de plus pour un tarif un
peu plus de 100 euros on lui en voudra
pas par contre de la même manière comme
sur le paceman de l'es19 vous allez
pouvoir filmer jusqu'en 1080p 1920 par
1080 à 60 images par seconde de notre
côté avez vous besoin de filmer en tête
qu'à souhaiter vous filmer en cas de cas
lorsque vous achetez un smartphone ou
d'un peu plus de 200 euros je vous
laisse répondre à cette question en bas
en commentaire il est pas trop mal ce
smartphone aurait tordu un petit peu
pour la vidéo on est sur les capteurs
arrière mais il 80 p 60 images par
seconde
ça fonctionne c'est par là dessus voir
faire les vidéos les plus folles les
photos les plus folles mais pour
quelques souvenirs et en rangs du
classique vous serez pas déçus le mode
portrait n'est pas complètement dingue
ça fonctionne
voilà on ne va pas lui en demander plus
ce n'est pas un smartphone optimisé pour
la photo pour moi ce smartphone
ce smartphone équilibré qui va vous
proposer une solution intéressante à
smartphone suffisamment puissant pour
pouvoir faire tourner trois cas avoir un
peu plus de toutes les applications du
plextor et compagnie ça c'est cool pour
vos usages l'autonomie est sérieuse les
photos sont pas mal l'écran est de bonne
qualité pour le multimédia pour les jeux
vidéo
pour moi on est sur un smartphone qui
franchement très intéressant lorsque
vous voulez pas dépenser trop d'argent
nouveau derrière une fiche technique
solide et un smartphone qui pourra vous
accompagner partout
donc pour moi le au nord 10 la capelle
évolution due aux no fly zones
et plus loin on vraiment tenu compte des
standards actuels pour garder un
smartphone d'entrée milieu de gamme
vraiment dans l'air du temps
ça c'est vraiment une mission réussie et
deuxièmement si intéressant c'est à dire
quelle est la différence réelle cas sont
les différences réelles entre le au nord
d'islamabad ps marc 2019 pour moi il ya
de grosses différences la première c'est
effectivement ce qu'on retrouvait au
niveau de la caméra avant 8 mégapixels
24 mégapixels
mais au delà de ça c'est vraiment un
beau 24 mégapixels le
je suis pas hyper hyper fan et la
deuxième différence c'est le prix c'est
assez bizarre parce que ceux aux normes
flight est moins cher que le huawei des
smart 2019
ça se joue à pas grand chose et le prix
va différer en fonction de revendeurs à
l'autre d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse
aux amis les liens en bas dans la
description vous pouvez aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil à la question est ce
que je dois acheter ceux au nord
d'islamabad wad devoir acheter bon je
dirais non on doit pas l'acheter par
contre est-ce que je peux l'acheter est
ce que c'est un bon smartphone d'entrée
milieu de gamme pour moi ouais ouais
ouais oui oui oui c'est mieux que web
pour moi oui c'est un bon smartphone
c'est un bon équilibre
c'est un smartphone qui fait quelques
promesses je trouve qu il les tient
c'est intéressant
voilà après je sais pas vous ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
le 9 lite qui est juste là est ce qu'il
vous a plu est-ce que vous avez le dise
light est ce que vous avez déjà un
smartphone de honor et si c'est pas le
cas est-ce que vous avez un smartphone
dans ce budget 200 220 230 240 euros
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ceux au
nord d'islamabad vous faire l'oeil vous
marquez tous formats et je vous invite à
les consulter ma playlist vous allez
trouver bien évidemment le test du ps
marc 2019 2019 du mal à articuler et
plein d'autres smartphones ça c'est cool
et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner parce
que d'ici quelques jours on part
directement voir le nouveau smartphone
les nouveaux smartphones de samsung se
doit ou est ce chao mis ce tout le monde
se donne cinq solos ico va y avoir plein
de trucs hyper cool ou vous embrasse
à très bientôt ciao